I know we sent chin on this date I can
be more excited about it ibid even asked
I didn't even ask
I'd even look on social media I didn't
wanna know how it went nothing I've been
saving it just for this well I saw one
picture of chin like feeding her and I
was a grill just alive well that's a
bite that I don't get that's you're
thinking I'm bad there's 40 carbs for
daddy that are going astray Nick what do
we have what do we do for chin get us
into this world uh they went out on
isn't Derrick and Lina do it he's got
the video go bro you know what's up Dee
oh this video I haven't seen either Nick
Nick put the video together first do we
need to ask Jimmy question before we go
this which should we watch this first I
think we watch this little sizzle reel
and then we'll get the recap from chin
and then we can FaceTime Carly later and
see what dude that's the worst name for
a girl that's not it you know she liked
it yeah did you call her Carlton at all
during the day I called her Tina that's
beautiful man Tito yeah Tito so
obviously chin us a little bit of that
Aaron Hernandez Nathan women man and
still trying to hook up with nobody
oh that's a gateway drug to Olive yeah
let's call chintz quarterback in high
school I'm right now just kidding this
is the first date this is the first
gender date right oh yeah wait real
quick Kat were you there yes I was
were you there Dan I was with you at San
Jose okay I see T Nick yep and so was
our videographer Mike now who really
hooked it up we threw together basically
an episode of blind date with a
three-man team
I've seen a lot of blind date so hey do
you or do you mean blind date or To
Catch a Predator all right well I don't
trust Cheney they're uneven you guys to
talk about right now but I also do not
trust
or chinnese as they call them
well my plan for tonight was to do what
a typical free night is right so usually
could go we'd grab drinks get Korean
barbecue grab dessert which is usually
boba if you're Asian you know exactly
what I'm talking about
and I think boba that I love that I want
her to try and then afterwards small of
them could all be okie studio and get
even more drinks yeah and then let me do
what I think I do best
yeah yeah yeah look at my boys saying
mmm I think you might know this but it's
been a while I'm gonna be honest in cat
I've never in my life ever been on a
date with what we would call a meet Jang
a white girl that's the N word for white
girl in fine Wow hey also known as a
cracker where I come from how dare you
Jim Wow watch the show Brendan check out
the books on Carly someone of another
race for you no I'm not I don't really
know it's more just like another date
just ribs in her bra do not put your
pants on your breakup that little big
well what are we sit on there bear that
idea you'd be farting chin coral is the
nose piercing drinking having fun he
said lot more Rudy said let's tighten up
girl who seems nice on the grill Jun did
you do it they just thought make her
cook that [ __ ]
okay second a to the ninth date second
date to life keeping cookin damn [ __ ]
under that meat boy hey bro that sizzler
hater
Oh Richard think it's juicy boy Amon I
should juicy grabbing our West
[Music]
post date with cat here we go you know
what it looked better than I thought it
would be - dude that's why I've never
dated an Asian man or any man for that
matter I'm glad we saw that and you know
leave me alone so now do we do does it
go to like
chinder after dark is that it we do have
a sizzle reel just for you guys to watch
in studio because we thought to watch
the whole thing it'd be a bit much but
we've got like a 12 minute thing that's
gonna drop the same time this episode
does that you see a little bit more of
their conversation but but Korean
barbecue was the entire date so that was
it and then we also have a little exit
interview with Jin here that might be
the highlight yeah all right I'm gonna
be honest I didn't think I would like
her that much she's white but she's
actually pretty [ __ ] cool yeah very
funny and sweet and nice and we got
along pretty well it's gonna sound
really the head but she's we sat next to
each other right and every time we would
take shots together her tits are good my
speaker and as soon as I would take a
shot I would see it and they were just
well would look to see through it jiggle
where we like Jane it was good we lost
well [ __ ] you know you lot we we've
been winning the entire game and you
threw [ __ ] the only way we came
I'm on it yeah because today I'll
supposed to go karaoke with her too and
then I think it was just so perfect that
we should just leave this alone and then
do a second date with karaoke and then
also I hope she wears something low top
because good job Kat that's nice you
know you you're winning off all three
quarters we got in the fourth you know
panic dude I know honestly why didn't ya
why didn't things escalate cuz it seemed
like you guys had a nice time at the
dinner y'all was doing the meat and
everything somebody had you had two or
three types of meat out there's on the
wobbly pop she's laughing wobbly for
sure yeah
so why not take it to karaoke and we get
that night vision out ah very oaky where
you guys get bear hair yeah I mean if we
went to karaoke I know for Oh first of
all ending it that way was probably
perfect like you know oh yeah you're at
a peak of like it's awesome in it there
and then if I will karaoke I know what I
could do there yeah and then stuff can
happen after that
yeah those sweater puppies I'm not gonna
have you guys filming her after karaoke
yeah dude I mean you could film that on
your own yeah you could do something
yeah we could do a drawing of it I would
do it for you yeah dinner was 2 hours
and 20 minutes to like they just can't
we Kat Mike and I all ate Korean
barbecue at the same time and we were
done like an hour in and they just kept
had food and drinks coming out like they
had a blast and after the date Carly
just kept saying I'm down for anything
I'm down for anything but she wasn't
down for Chinni thing bro she was yes
she was early fumble fumble dude he's
dressed like George Michael did in a
funeral of course and fumble dude he
looks like somebody that plays a
keyboard in a lotta edit on a late night
television she fumbled broke in is one
step away from a deaf guy
- of course it was great hot car was so
down dude and your superpowers singing
you didn't get there but nobody I think
you played a smart move be good be gone
that's the move you do well you do and
you get out you were there cat you were
on the front lines
what was the female perspective of this
uh of this little Vietnam
nom-nom-nom-nom because they ate for two
hours hey who paid for this thing huh do
we pay really we did did we later yeah
okay it was good chin was killing it in
the beginning and he lost energy right
no it wasn't that it was she's gonna
tell a little too much energy towards
the end in the post interview like you
said but to be fair she also was very
tipsy she was down to have like not just
a good night but maybe like a good
morning if there they went to carry a
girl what she was wrong little cause the
bad exit interview with her yeah we had
a part of it in that clip action that'll
be in the longer thing on YouTube you
can check it out on yeah and we can talk
to her we can go straight to her face
timer work I was he's still recovering
from the GHB meet that chin was serving
over there dude okay from that [ __ ]
beef teriyaki dipped in night quilt you
never can be scary yeah I do
so this familiar that was a snake will
that be very sleepy chin with surfer
dude melatonin chicken our check Bill
Cosby [ __ ] skewers baby then be cosby
fritters over there
well enough be cosby falafels baby on a
pillow of rice dude a huge pillow of
rice based on a bed what are we gonna
talk to you about first let's just don't
call her blindly dude listen yeah you
suck with women yeah you have to laugh
for last time real do you like TV oh
yeah cuz I want to be prepared okay we
just saw what happens you don't prepare
and go out with somebody I know you talk
about her tits god dammit Jim I thought
it's gonna be real cute chills like yeah
I'll call this thing in the whole time
is yeah as soon as you a dude cheers me
in a [ __ ] we get squeezed together in
my mouth now what's all the real chin
came out shady um yeah so what are we
gonna talk to her about chopsticks if we
could to say how was the evening okay
well here's the thing Jim would you go
on a second that's a weenie did you have
fun
where did he mess up did you go did you
go on a date after that did you have a
friend pick you up from there did you go
do some other karaoke Wow
yes you might have maybe she hadn't
liked him or she was like I was down for
more and then chin just took off talking
about you know some [ __ ] the head to
go do sing in his bedroom so I had my
friend pick me up yeah we sent her in an
uber home and it was going to the
address she gave she was originally
picked up at but she asked to take a
detour and she ended up going to Newport
Beach she party more that night you know
really yeah yeah good Wow let's see how
this doesn't matter just really kids
adjacent care to get Nass you might have
had an assist bro
back off my broccolini get your life
together
I'm not touching